the church is brought to you by nature
box listen you all want to eat better
but when it comes to snacks sometimes it
feels like the whole world is delicious
and has a billion calories versus boring
and tasteless
it doesn't have to be that way up your
snack game with nature box and right now
you'll save even more nature box is
offering you guys the family three free
snacks with your first order when you go
to naturebox.com
joey again that's naturebox.com
joey for three free snacks with your
first order that's naturebox.com
joey number two listen august is coming
july was hot enough
july is hot enough and you still didn't
get your bidet well let me tell you
something what august is gonna do to you
with that mugginess in your [__]
you're not gonna get over it everybody
wants to have a date everybody wants to
go on match.com but you're walking
around with a filthy [__] [__] and
a dirty nut sack that's why it is
hellotushy.com bidets are back [__]
portable bidets are back that's what
hello tushy does right now go to
hellotushy.com and i'll give you 10 off
by pressing go to hellotoshi.com church
bam watch that muffler keep it nice and
refreshed the summer's here you don't
want to be a [__] slob you understand
me go to hellotushy.com
kick this mule lee
the church of what's happened now the
fifth hundredth episode
july 19 19
whatever the [__] it is
kick this mule lee i want to see [__]
oh [__]
this is you little savages the beautiful
people
the church of what's happened now
lee syed
mr greg garcia
and your uncle
joey what do you think of that
it's that [__] simple
i don't even know how to introduce you
mr g i don't know if it's creator
executive producer director writer
because you've done [__] everything
so it really doesn't matter we want to
welcome on our fifth hunter episode mr
greg garcia it's an honor man thanks for
having me please this is uh great this
is great this is first of all i want to
tell you
that you're one of the best bosses i
ever had ah that's up there with sam
raimi i got you up there the sam was
[__] very all right yeah like saying
what's going on i don't know just go
hang out i'll get you later
we like to have a good time yeah and
that's what we spent some time in prison
together yes we did
out there in lancaster right
the [__] desert well it was that's
right talk about hot
and we shot like in august yeah we shot
in the
middle oh my god it was brutal out there
that's right walking around with like
towels on wet towels on our head and
just trying to stay cool but good lord
it was rough out there and we were in a
in a place that was
half closed and half operational that
prison we were in half of it was being
used for uh
uh illegal immigrants who got arrested
but not for like anything too serious
and they were just awaiting uh
deportation so they were just chill they
were just playing soccer and hanging out
and watching us and stuff but we were
another half of it
i remember one of the scenes i shot was
the guy hitting the head you hit the
head yeah you hit he went to break we're
talking about my name is earl he's the
creator my name is earl and just you
know yes dear
the list goes on and on i know lee said
you worked on family matters family
members yeah i did that one for a year
yeah yeah that was fun
your jimmy runs deep you know what i'm
saying you're jimmy runs [__]
you don't need no introduction now you
got a new show got a new show coming out
uh yeah august 3rd called the guest book
yeah good that's the news you always got
something going on i try you know uh you
know it's got to the point now too that
like i've i've been lucky enough that i
can just do some stuff that's fun you
know i don't have to chase anything too
much this new one's this new one's fun
yeah you know when i think of you
sometimes
like i'll see an old my name is earl at
night or the other one that you did with
the with the old lady yeah yeah raising
hope oh with cloris leech gloriously she
used to lick my neck let me tell you
something she's [__] nuts crazy the
other day i'm in my hotel room and
wherever the [__] i was the longest yard
was on yeah i hate watching myself on tv
but as i was scrolling it was the scene
with her and adam when she's got
stockings on she loves that and i
remember and i busted out at the table
she pulled up her shirt yeah and showed
everybody oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
she'll do it do whatever she doesn't
care she would lick me she'd come and
lick me on my neck while i'd be sitting
there watching the monitors and one day
i sprayed a bitter apple all over my
neck like the stuff you put on the
furniture so dogs don't chew it that
tastes all bad and she started licking
and then she stopped and i said what's
wrong she said you're a little after
nuni
yeah but it didn't stop her she kept
doing it she kept looking [__]
tremendous and raised you know
but uh it's just no no you're one of
these guys that
you're so innovative with it's a little
different tv and what where the [__]
they do like you're always right there
then you had another show at one time
that was crazy also i had uh well i had
earlier before that
no i had no i just just yesterday i
worked on family guy for a little bit
uh yes dear uh i had a show called the
built to last that was ironically built
to last with royale watkins that lasted
uh maybe three episodes yeah yeah nbc
nbc it lasted three episodes that was a
long that long time ago co-created that
with warren hutcherson stand up
yeah yeah good guy yeah so that must
have been 17 years ago it was a long
time ago i was probably 26
27 years old yeah yeah yeah built to
last it was wow i just saw royale did
you yeah you see him from time to time
yeah okay good
good i hope he's doing good he's a good
guy
television is so hard
and you make it you know right now at
this point you know the proof is in the
pudding you've made it look so easy yeah
you got to surround yourself with the
right people too though i mean i think
it's a lot of that you know i met a lot
of good writers
worked with a lot of good actors that
would come back and work on other things
too and you know it's so it's luck too
because you could do the best show
ever if it's not on the right network at
the right time it's done you know you
gotta just you gotta thread the needle
almost every time
it's tough when did you know you wanted
to become a television writer i watched
tv my whole life you know sitcoms and
stuff that's all i did i wouldn't read
books i would just watch sitcoms
you know one of the
you're really funny a lot of stuff a lot
of stuff uh in reruns during the day
like happy days and father knows best
and leave it to beaver and samford and
sun and you know
what's happening and all that stuff you
know those were my
my shows and so much so that when we had
dinner
i didn't want to stop watching but i had
to go upstairs and have dinner so i
would set up a little cassette recorder
because we didn't have vcrs you know so
i set a cassette recorder i just audio
record it then i'd come down when like
wheel of fortune and jeopardy were on
which i didn't care about and i'd listen
to them which would force you to kind of
like direct it in your head you'd have
to like move the people around and
whatever so like looking back on it that
was kind of like a tool you know to
start like thinking about how to how to
actually do one of these things you know
that's [__] brilliant yeah that's how
i learned to speak the language yeah so
for me it was dick van dyke it was room
222 yeah courtship of eddie's father
uh you know the waltons [__] was
tremendous i still remember the night
that
happy days premiered yeah i was in the
fourth grade and i was at sacred heart
school for boys uh-huh and
that's what you watch yeah you watch tv
like from seven to nine yeah and i still
remember the night
happy days for me and shortly after that
was
i know if you were watching happy days
like 16
4th graders you know we would have
snacks like whatever
and all of a sudden the television
stopped one day and it was
the trailer for bruce lee's the chinese
connection okay and during commercials
like we just go crazy that none will
come out and say shut up
stop it stop it
and i'll never forget that we were
watching happy days and awesome i saw
bruce lee like i had seen him on the
green i won it before but now he was in
a [__] movie like when they took the
green horn off tv people it's not like
today that they had variety yeah like
what the [__] happened i didn't know
yeah i didn't know what i was just gone
what happened six episodes he was
beating up white people they took him
off like nobody can fill you in nobody
can film it's a mystery so he
disappeared so fist the fury
it's all you know the chinese released
them really weird so the first bruce lee
movie that came out didn't come out like
they just put it in chinatown there was
no big advertising it must have caught
on and that's when they released the
chinese connection with my in my world
that's the best one that's the one when
he goes [__] nuts and
i still remember the trailer i'm playing
and the whole room you can hear a
[__] pen drive yeah
and after the commercial went off
everybody in that room like just
exploded like i'm going friday i'm going
friday i'm calling my father right now
like people are just going nuts yeah
like when your mom picked you up on
friday like what do you want to do this
weekend you want to go
to the restaurant you're like i want to
go see bruce lee like yeah everybody was
[__] yelling that's why yeah i
remember happy days i don't think i ever
missed an episode of these days i love
them and then when i was this is crazy
yeah
let me tell you this so i'm in my i'm in
my backyard in virginia
um i'm probably i don't know 11 12 13
years old something like that i look
over the fence the new neighbors moved
in right behind us you remember jenny
piccolo
jenny piccolo she played joey's joanie's
friend her friend right right jenny
piccolo moved behind me
in virginia over the fence and she
married a dentist and the show was over
and she was just living there and blew
my mind because you know i'm just
worshiping people on the tv and watching
it now one's right over the back fence i
never talked to her was terrified
wouldn't look in her direction i would
sit in our little sun room we had a
piano and i would would she even be in
the backyard and i'd play like happy
days on the piano but i'd like hide
under the under the window and then
eventually she moved but it was it was a
mind-blowing experience you know like
holy [__] like here in virginia yeah
we're in virginia right in my backyard
my favorite [__] tv show yeah the
girl that's on that show
just
just moved right there crazy
crazy
so so yeah so i watched you know i just
watched sitcoms like crazy i went to
this little college in um frostburg uh
maryland called frostburg state
university tiny little school osats no
s.a.t is needed yeah you know how like
if you're supposed to tell like if a dog
is smart you put a blanket over its head
how long it gets out that's pretty much
the test to get into frostburg it was a
tiny little school
but
there was a tv writing class just as a
fluke
and i decided why not i'll take it i
like tv and uh the night before i was
supposed to turn in a script
i didn't have a script and i just took a
bunch of caffeine pills stayed up all
night long wrote a cheer script read it
the next day people laughed and i was
like this is cool i like this i like
this and then
they had something hooked up with warner
brothers and they sent my script to
warner brothers and i got picked to go
out there for two weeks so i was working
for um
tony kornheiser the espn uh pti he had a
radio show in dc i was working for him
and i said look i got to go for two
weeks to this uh to la to check out this
tv stuff i got picked for you know for
this contest
so i went out to this show uh room for
two with linda lavin and patricia heaton
and i just hung out with the writers got
a couple jokes in
they said you should do this
no guarantees i went back saved up like
two grand got my car
drove out here knew a guy that worked at
a foot locker in orange county i slept
on his couch
did some extra work on 90210 and some
other stuff just to make some money when
i got here got a job as a pa and uh as a
writer on the with the writers and next
thing i knew i got my first job the next
year so
just hustled a little bit which was
on our own with a comedian now named
ralph harris
and this family called the smallett
family there was a bunch of them uh that
were actually related so they played
brothers and sisters on the show there's
like seven or eight of them or something
and the the thing was it was one of
those tgif shows you know like family
matters and those shows that were on abc
on friday nights you know real family
oriented shows and the premise was about
as stock as you could get for a sitcom
their parents had died and their older
brother played by ralph harris had to
dress up like their aunt so they could
all stay together and of course the guy
that's in charge of like social services
he's in love with him when he dresses up
like the aunt so there's a lot of jokes
like that and it was just it wasn't
great it wasn't great but uh i remember
the first day i said why can't he dress
up like the uncle and they're all like
hey man
you can [__] up the whole show
don't say that
so yeah that was the first one it lasted
a season lasted one season
and uh then i went to family matters
with ol urkel after that for a couple
seasons and then i did that uh built to
last we talked about
wow so you got here one year 93
so you moved out here in 93. four years
before i got here so you've been here 24
years now yeah yeah you know you blink
an eye and it's it's like good lord how
long i've been in
your [__] life yeah it's crazy
you know you you you start to
think about you know jesus you know you
think about yourself from one place and
then all of a sudden you look up and
you're like i've been here longer than
there
you know it's crazy
time [__] flies man
i still remember reading
i don't know if you remember this
remember they tried to turn the 20
cornheiser show into a tv show
absolutely yeah and i wanted to read for
something in that tv they did it for a
little bit with jason alexander yeah
called listen up something they did
something i still remember reading and
going who the [__] is tony kornheiser
yeah i'm not a big sports radio guy yeah
but they were telling me at the audition
yeah they gave him a show and i'm like
what the [__] so yeah it was funny
because i was doing yesterday at the
time and they took us off the schedule
they didn't have us on the fall schedule
they put his show in our slot so i
called him up on the air and i said hey
[__] i said look you hold a
grudge man i left your show and uh 15
years later you got to come take my my
slot you know he was laughing about that
now yes dia was the guy from boston
anthony clark anthony clark yeah you had
gardell on there gardell came on there a
bunch a bunch because because it was a
time where like uh before yes dear i was
having all these meetings with uh
comedians that had deals and uh i met
with gardell and i just had a great time
at the meeting we didn't do anything i
mean but i was meeting with like mitch
hedberg and joe rogan and all these
people i'd have these great meetings and
then nothing would come out of it but i
remember gardelle just made me laugh
like [__] they all did but um
so i look up in the audience one day
yesterday and he's there because his
buddy's doing like a one two line thing
on the show and i see him again i'm like
man we got to get you on here and then
he ended up doing like 30 episodes or
something that's right yeah billy on
there that was it that are you
like talking about watching sitcoms
after school yes dear i think i i might
have been in middle school or high
school that was huge like that was my
like 3 p.m tbs it was yes deer it was
king of queens yeah it was i think it
was everybody loves raymond
it's we it seems like in the last like
10 years or so i don't know how long
sitcoms have like they kind of get a bad
rap and i don't know they're like just
thinking about it ever since you come
home from school that's what it is it's
like it's sitcom it's you know look the
thing is is like there's a different
there's so many people out there there's
different audiences for different shows
so like the people that give like four
camera sitcoms a bad rap they don't like
them that's fine you know but i'll talk
to people that run into me and they'll
go oh yeah yeah yeah i love that show
yes dear and my name is earl i i i don't
care for that one you know but yes dear
is the one and then you to meet other
people and other people flips you know
so
a lot of people out there you know so so
but definitely four camera shows they
get a bad rap but that's because most of
the people that write about that stuff
doesn't like those and it was i don't
know because i was watching them and
they were in syndication so like tbs i
think ran them in order a little bit but
not really so i like i got to watch
i i it got to be like i don't know like
they were you seem to do shows where
they're not always
like the the jockey like really like
like in yesterday it's a nerdy guy and a
loser living in a pool house yeah like
like like both like i kind of relate
more to the nerdy guy a little bit but
everyone wants like all the nerds want
to be the cool guy in the pool house so
it was just
like looking when i saw that you did
that show and then family me like it's
just it's uh
you look when you look back at those
shows now for me at least it's like i
think of childhood even though it's like
i didn't watch yesterday as it was
airing i watched it later on but it was
it means childhood to me it's like a tv
like i don't know it's all these nerds i
think tv means a lot more than just
everybody it means a lot to me why do
you think when i go pitch i always try
to pitch up with a 70s team yeah i
[__] because
you just get you know that's the time
for you you know just like you know you
come home from school that's your break
these people are influencing your lives
i pitch with a 70s theme and people look
at me especially now that everybody's
remaking [__] yeah i'm like guys this is
the way to [__] pitch yeah i want to
pitch family affair that's with
sebastian cabot and the [__] good
looking dude yeah yeah buffy and jody
and jody yeah i've been dying to repitch
that for 30 [__] years people say
nobody wants to [__] do it no that's
the show that's the show but then they
no they did they we did the odd couple
right cbs did the they did the odd cup
no that did not work then somebody did
the other one we discussed
which one
the sports ship of eddie's father abc
tried to crack on yeah yeah cause i went
in for the [__] uncle that's right
but this had to be still jeff getler was
my manager so it had to be [__] 17.
they tried family affair at one point
too no they yeah they did i'm telling
you they did you can look it up they did
it on uh when warner brothers had a
network i think
yeah they didn't do a good job of it no
because they got to do it for 2017. yeah
sebastian cabot is a [__] english guy
they know english people love living in
your houses they're mexican
exactly that's why i come in you follow
what i'm saying yeah i'm the sebastian
cabbage dude because the dude is
supposed to be a [__] hot single
bachelor let's make him
a hot single [__] bachelor yeah and
i'm the guy that takes care of his house
when he's away i smoke dope i drive his
car you know what i'm saying i make sure
nobody breaks in yeah this guy travels
the world a ceo for something it could
be the dude from sons anarchy i don't
give a [__] and i'm the host on his
three nieces show up
the family house bro whatever they were
yeah it was like the three and all the
kids showed up one after the other
uh-huh if you watch the pile yeah yeah
yeah they didn't come together right no
they didn't come together it was like
one came at two in the afternoon the
other one showed at 6 30 and the other
one showed the following morning really
i mean so
that's at any age yeah any [__] age
you know i don't even want to get
rehooked and i love lucy it took me it
was worse than coke getting off i love
lucy worst and coke yeah once you get
into i love lucy's like i don't even
[__] with those things no more i'm done
for a long time i was proud ricky
ricardo i'm cuban i can't do it yeah
because i actually go back the other
night i watch the honeymooners i watch
the honeymoon every saturday night
sunday night at 11 on channel 20. that
wee channel that has oh yeah i just
recorded a bunch of uh andy griffiths
i'm gonna watch with my 10 year old yeah
yeah yeah they got everything columbo
night stalker that kochak they got
everything on there you just gotta get
they even have rat patrol yeah no they
even had a couple months ago they had
like they ran uh
the wild wild west f troop yeah i'm
always curious when i watch it with my
kids too like what'll hit and what won't
because it's such like we were saying
it's so formidable years for us you know
it just gets in there you know there's
something about
those years i mean i'm i'm a big 70 70s
guy too you know as soon as i had a
little bit of money first thing i did
was buy a smoky and a bandit trans am
you know it was like that was the
coolest car i've ever seen in my life
watching those movies and i had to i had
to have the damn thing but now you know
then my kids look at me like what the
[__] what is that car over there you
know but there's something about those
early years that just
do you remember
when people used to turn you onto black
and white [__] and you tell them to go
[__] you
like when i was a kid you showed me
something black and white yeah go [__]
yourself yeah yeah what is this i'm
telling you it's a classic it's it's uh
uh what's the one with the [__] long
shoulder with marlon brando oh yeah i'll
never forget this guy trying to sell it
to me i'm like listen i'm not watching
that [__] black and white movie he's
like it's marlon brando it's on the
waterfront i don't give a [__]
put color tv on okay like i refuse that
one age that's funny and i'll tell you
what made me switch the twilight zone oh
yeah because once you get hooked on the
toilet you know what the twilight zones
you get hooked on those you're like i
might as well [__] watch like that's
a show that you can't remake oh
absolutely they tried and somebody died
just as the kiss of death
somebody didn't somebody die in the set
oh yeah yeah yeah they tried they can't
don't [__] with that show yes it's just
too much it's just and and the
excitement of being something different
every week to that show which was which
was great you've watched that uh you
seen that black mirror
it's like an hour twilight zone it's on
netflix it's crazy i think my wife
watches it it's good it's good and it's
like twilight zone it's just weird [__]
that happens except it's an hour and you
know it's more uh you know it's updated
now but but uh it's good it's good you
should check that out
now i didn't know who greg garcia was i
don't know dick about dick
i'm just a comedian who goes out every
night gets on stage as much as he can
and i'm doing blow and i'm trying to
survive you know what i'm saying
you know what made me another thing that
made me quit doing blow that last
episode with tim stacks tim stack
set him on fire
on fire watch him burn dude
if you watch that my tooth is black okay
and people always go to me man you're
brilliant you made your toothbrush that
wasn't that [__] brilliant that was
the cocaine starting to come through the
enamel oh [__] i went to a dentist two
weeks later and he fixed it yeah but
that that's how crazy like how was that
that was the last i think i quit doing
coke yeah 10 years ago but i didn't know
nothing about nothing and one night i
couldn't find the remote control and it
was an episode of my name is earl with
john leguizamo with mexico oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah and i'm [__] dying i left
that house going who the [__] does these
things anymore that was how you that was
how i fell in love with
you with greg garcia that was the
episode
him and three other mexicans oh yeah he
was crazy oh you also had the guy from
sansani that episode oh yeah yeah you
had uh broccoli tacos yeah whatever yeah
yeah uh you know that yeah yeah yeah i'm
blanking on his name me too yeah it's
got the taco places oh danny trejo danny
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's right i was
like this is [__] crazy
this is crazy yeah that was nuts what is
nbc doing like nbc's really [__]
because it wasn't about that time i've
been telling people this nobody
remembers you're gonna remember greg
garcia
what was the show nbc tried to push one
day about jesus on vikings
oh
[__] what was that oh what was that
called that [__] lasted oh yeah three
episodes yeah somebody was they tied up
the executive who greenlit that yeah
just giving them backhands oh that was a
big miss but yeah i remember jesus on
vicodin and he had a daughter
and he was traveling across the country
yeah oh my god lee this was when i read
about it because i think i wanted to
read for it i read for the pilot and i
go this is not yeah i had to go i
thought about that that didn't that
didn't last long there was no cable back
then there was no like big cable no
so i'm like this is not getting picked
up on nbc yeah and i remember even like
when i go to auditions i'll log four
pages like i'll log a page and go my
name is earl for the part of vinnie
call back
and i'll never forget that they released
the pilots and i even got the notebook
to see if that pilot go
they picked it up
oh my god i [__] up
i was like i thought and then it lasted
after the first episode a bunch of
[__] christians went nuts oh yeah
midwest i can't even imagine they went
nuts in the midwest then episode two he
did something even crazy cop coke yeah
and they really pushed piece
yeah that's crazy yeah
even when we so when we came along to do
earl like they didn't have anything you
know crazy we were doing stuff that they
hadn't done either and uh which was cool
they had the office but nobody was
watching the office yet but they had the
office on and uh it was good um and then
uh and then we brought this to them
but that you know this saddle that that
show sat on a shelf for a year and a
half nobody wanted to do it it just sat
there my name is my name is earl yeah i
was doing the show yesterday and i knew
i had to write something if i wanted to
go work on a single camera comedy
i know how people are like i wasn't
going to get a job on arrested
development or malcolm in the middle or
bernie mac if they just look to see that
i did yes dear because i go oh it's a
four camera guy you know yeah yeah he
did a lot of them but it's a four camera
so i was like i gotta write i gotta
write a script that's more
like their shows or not like their shows
but single camera little edgier what
have you so i just sat down to write it
and then i was like i like this so i
tried to sell it nobody would buy it so
about a month you know a year and a half
later nbc they have a meeting with me
and they're like hey we read that script
you wrote my name is earl we'd like to
do a show with you and i was like well
how about we do that one man
because they're hard to come up with if
you like it and they talked about it and
they're like yeah let's take a shot so
thank god they did you know but uh uh it
was a long road to get that thing showed
me a favor mr g for me and for the
people at home i never asked you this
what's the breakdown i don't know
[__] one camera four cameras oh
gotcha break it down all right so the
four cameras a show like uh sitcoms
you're kind of used to like um uh king
of queens everybody loves raymond it
just looks like a play you know there's
not that happy days whatever camera
that's a four camera so basically you've
got four cameras just pointing at all
the actors okay so you don't have that
fourth wall there you know people can't
people kind of talk sideways to each
other and everything because it's just
like you're shooting a play and you
shoot it in about four or five hours and
then you're just done
single camera which actually you
normally have two cameras but they call
it single camera looks more like a movie
so that's more like the traditional
movie making you and i are talking to
each other we're going to get your
coverage now we're going to take 20
minutes to turn all the lights around
and get my coverage right
that's single camera yeah so shows like
you know uh
my name is earl raisin hope that i did
but like i said bernie mac arrested
development those are all single camera
shows so you got to shoot those things
five days a week 14 hours a day so for
the actors single camera is brutal
for multi-cam
that's the best schedule if you're an
actor because you you you work about 20
hours a week and you shoot the whole
show in five hours and then it's just
done what's the [__] what do the soap
operas use that's more like a four
camera kind of thing yeah cause they
[__] they fly no no they fly i
tell people all the time i booked the
general hospital look at me uncle joey
[Laughter]
a three episode [__] thing i couldn't
believe it yeah my agent called me goes
hey uh
oh and general hospital called they
wanted to send a real you mind i go sure
yeah they're gonna hire me a week later
he's like yeah they want to hire you for
three episodes and i tell people
if i would have got hired for that when
i first moved to l.a i would have got
fired
yeah i would have how so
when i got to my name is earl somebody
greets me and they go joey hi my name is
penelope i'm the first a.d your call
times are two that's your trailer lunch
is over here this and this there's a
script waiting for you we'll take you to
wardrobe then they take your wardrobe
you come back and the wardrobe's not
ready for you then we'll take you to
makeup and you come back and they talk
to you and then have you met greg yeah
no come on let's walk you over to the
side greg this is joey oh my god i like
your reed nice to meet you mr g all
right no problem we're gonna have fun
today you know and then you go back
that's a usual set yeah
general hospital you pull up to that
[__] abc you give them a license they
look at it they look at you
they run you in
they tell you what spot to park in go to
331 it's by the [__] book
not a long walk either like there's not
a lot of cars up there it's not like a
half a mile like regular lots yeah you
know where they shoot it right like no
uh sunset
if you go straight east okay instead of
going towards echo you shoot up that
street that creepy street up there
that's where they shoot okay so they
have like a really weird street they
used to audition a lot when i first
moved here no more up there for
different stuff you go in you show me id
lady tells you what room you're in
you're in room 209 okay you walked it to
room 209
your wardrobe is there your contract is
on the table there's a pen
there's a little refrigerator a few
waters
now one [__] soul comes and talks to
you there's two monitors
there's a model that shows you what
they're shooting and there's a mother
that tells you when to go out okay
that's it
not human interaction not a [__] one
it's like him with his sushi he went to
the conveyor belt sushi and [__] no
human interaction you know what i'm
saying yeah so
but it was so weird somebody finally
came in and said are you ready yes okay
they'll tell you on the thing when they
even come out
they'll say scene 28a and 28b upcoming
29a you got to go out there yeah you're
on deck and like okay if i shoot
something for you and you're like joey
say the line lee let's finish here and
let's go get some [__] potato tacos
okay
if i go lee let's finish here and
sorry
you don't start the line from scratch
yeah sorry you start the line where you
[__] it up like it was the quickest
shooting really there was no drama and
do they start shooting right away you
get one to rehearse or you just you get
you get one block okay so the camera the
tv also tells you when to go block okay
and once you go block there's no like
people mingling
like you don't want to start taking yeah
with somebody to call no they don't know
me everybody's in their [__] room
yeah like it's the end of the world like
that mom just dropped and then it says
come out you go out there there's final
touches
i mean it's like bam like i would get in
at
nine and be in the car at
10 45 wow and it's one a day
one episode of that episode yeah most
people have been there since you know
most of the people that dirty [__]
yes they got it down i would have never
cut the mustard if i would have came
here as a
rookie yeah that had a nervous breakdown
yeah so this is i don't really
i don't think a lot of people understand
this
so if you like audition for a role right
they give it to you you go to set
you're not doing well
they'll like you or whoever greg would
would go to them and be like yeah it's
not working out
we'll find another actor like you'll
just go down the list in the auditions
like that happens pretty regularly i've
only gotten fired one time again my
agent told me not to go back at
lunchtime telemundo really yeah i went
in there and read once i got there they
said they didn't like my spanish
but they paid for my after so would i
give a [__] yeah i haven't replaced a
lot of people i mean four camera shows
like i said those those things you
couldn't replace people because you
don't shoot it until the end of the week
so like you could have a table read and
if it's just not working and i've had a
situation where it's just not working
with people that like
you're excited to be there too like like
tv icons and it just didn't work and
you're like [__] you know and you gotta
you gotta replace it single camera
people come in they're shooting that day
you're gonna figure it out i mean
you know they they auditioned you saw
them they're good you know if if
unless you just offered it to them and
they uh and then they're just blowing it
but you're gonna have to figure it out
we've had those situations too jesus
it's uh speaking of firing people i
don't know i don't think you were
involved but you worked on
at least one show that
replaced a character family matters
replaced the the mother didn't they and
then i know you didn't work on it but
fresh prince of bel air like they
replaced the mom so like it happens
we're like the middle of a series
were pretty forgiving for that stuff
people were upset
i guess i mean i i don't know i i the
shows still go on so i figured they're
kind of i mean you know you got to you
know bewitched and that kind of stuff
where they switched the darren's and all
that thing so so it feels like you know
they can still survive it sometimes
we really don't know what's going on
behind the scenes either
it's it could be money
it could be someone's just a pain in the
ass somebody's a [__] pain in the ass
you know
i can't
live my life no matter what status like
i just read an article about mariah
carey on some movie yeah i heard about
that did you hear about yeah yeah yeah
that uh
[__] what movie was that the one with
will
and amy poehler
gambling right yeah she got in and then
she didn't want to sing that song that
day
yeah she just made up yeah she wanted to
do something completely different people
are crazy yeah i couldn't deal with that
at all yeah i i can't and i know there's
a lot of personalities involved in
shooting a film
or a tv tv even more because you got
upstairs watching every [__] move
but i can't deal with that diva
i've never seen i've never really seen
it like that anybody actually i've been
lucky i haven't seen it too much a
little bit here and there but uh but
yeah you just it's life's too short man
to put up with that [__] you know i mean
i i don't i kind of get the feeling that
people say sometimes like oh money
changed i have success changed that
person i i always kind of thought that
it just lets you be who you really are
like the people that are divas they
would have been like that before if they
could have got away with it i mean
that's that's that's my philosophy on it
i could be wrong but uh
it's just life's too short
you know it's funny you said uh
you said smoking the bandit
when i cast when i got castle along this
yard
seeing him
was
like everything yeah like i don't know
if you understand like in the 70s he was
everything oh please you know the other
night oh my god lee i didn't tell you
yeah i usually end the shows on saturday
nights and i'm one of these wackadoos i
take the first flight out mr g i got no
time for 10 a.m or 2 o'clock those are
the delayed ones next time when you're
drunk when you're on the 405 at four go
[__] yourself take the first flight out
you land at 8 45 and you could sleep
three or four hours absolutely do you
know what happened diana i [__] got
home saturday night and guess who's on
all american classics
[__] the getaway with steve mcqueen
now you know for some people i don't
know if you don't know who the [__]
steve mcqueen is guess what i forgot to
i forgot until i laid on the bed and
started watching and going
look at this [__] with a gun
they were in the have you ever seen that
movie yeah original yeah they were
already in the dumpster and they're
talking about her [__] the dude
she's like we can move forward if you'll
just let it go i chose you and he's
looking at his [__] that cannon of a
gun that he had he had a [__] cannon
and he's like okay and he grabs it you
know
we forget like you just [__] fight i
was sitting there going look at this
this is what lee has to watch yeah you
know he grabbed the hand they walked out
of the dumpster they [__] get to the
hotel
they they check in but they're laying
down they're about to [__]
you know they did the class act because
alex baldwin and his wife they [__]
and they showed you [__] and [__] not
steve mcqueen no steve mcqueen is not
[__] ally mcgraw on camera and [__]
he beat the [__] out of him in the
middle of the movie but he wouldn't [__]
around okay but he got up and he goes
you know what that dude is a [__]
wino
that dude his family is always around
him because if not he [__] he drinks
so he's a gambler something's not right
that's why he got up with the gun and
then the guy that looks like me
that guy that played salazo people
always told me when i was a kid that guy
looks like you yeah you know what i'm
talking about uh-uh i don't know that
one
he played salazo and he played the
getaway okay he's in the getaway see if
you get a scene from the getaway league
and when i was a kid people would always
tell me i looked like this yeah he
played salazo and the godfather and i
forget what that [__] guy's name is
in the getaway but i watched steve
mcqueen i watched his acting and [__]
he was [__] great yeah he was great
and bert what was your experience
huh i'm sorry ella turkey
yes what was your experience with bert
on the longest yard when you're when he
was there and you're working and and
like you know overall yeah overall it
was heavenly yeah overall it brought
tears to my eyes at times
you know like uh lee was saying
everybody everybody
gets you know everybody feels the same
about the people they grew up with yes
absolutely
because he did it my name is earl uh
what'd you think well jason lee and i
we're big fans you know okay and
everybody is everybody and we bonded
over that when our first meeting so
we're like man we had this strip club
called chubbies and it was supposedly
you know and we said it's owned by a guy
named chubby right and uh and he owned
everything in town and he was like this
mythical character and we're like well
we want to do an episode with chubby but
who's going gonna play him and we said
what about burt reynolds and jason was
like man
what if what if
what if it's not good you know we have
this image of him he's our hero what if
what if it turns bad you know cause you
hear stories about burt reynolds i mean
he doesn't really take any [__] and uh
and we're like i was like yeah but we
got to do it we got to do it so we put
an offer out and sure enough he said
he'd come do it so we had him for three
days first day he came in man was it
amazing just amazing talking to him
sitting he never left the set we talked
about stories he told me about
deliverance and hooper and smoking the
bandit and everything and i'm asking him
like why did you look into the camera at
that one point and he's telling me how
marlon brando told him he loved that
part all these great stories it was
amazing best day of my life everybody
went to audition with that [__] dude
and the guy brought a gun
when he was his roommate the dude was
his roommate in new york and he took him
to the audition yeah the guy was in the
movie with the [__] bowling movie not
the other one the one will farrell did
he's older well him and burt reynolds
were roommates and they went to an
audition on broadway for eli kazan
and the other guy brought a piece in and
he pulled it on he like kazan and then
the story when clint eastwood called him
and said we're going to go piss on that
producer's grave that fire this oh yeah
and they took motorcycles and they
pissed on his great you know just he's
crazy he no
what about when he showed up with dom
deluise
who shows up with dom de louise dog
with groceries to cook
okay you know what i'm saying
with a grill he showed up on the 50-yard
line
that's funny he showed up with dom
deluise arguing still [__] throwing
him they showed up he had groceries they
cooked i got something in the house you
might like oh my god i got something at
the house that you're really gonna like
he uh
so he was great man second day
he sat there and he told me the same
stories oh yeah
yeah i loved it i loved it and then the
third day he was he was in a little bit
of a mood and he had a scene where he
had to slap
uh one of the actors ethan sipley
and uh
we're we're just blocking it we're just
blocking it no cameras are even around
and it gets to that point and he slaps
him right in the face hard hard
and i was like oh [__]
so then we rehearsed it one more time
hard just slapped him hard
my god i said ethan uh you only say
something to him he goes no no no no i'm
not telling burt reynolds to pull a
punch no i'm not a [__] i'm not i'm not
i'm not doing that i'm not doing that i
said all right so then we're not even
getting his coverage he's
every time he's slapping him finally i
felt so bad i went to ethan and i said
i'm gonna give you 50 from now on
every time he slaps you and after we
were done shooting the scene i gave
ethan 950
and he had a mark on his face that
didn't go away for two days
and it's just bert doesn't play around
did you say he did to me in the longest
yard there's one scene along his yard
he actually fires out on me i could do
it today but at that time i was 400
[__] pounds yeah i couldn't breathe
he almost killed me
he was still strong
yeah like he was still strong don't ever
[__] like when he did the longest
shot he was messing around with us yeah
and he was still a mule i was terrified
of him
i didn't [__] with him he'd do something
and i go yeah that's good man go ahead
and i'll be like we're not going to use
that but you know i think that he i
think he he got a reputation
and then he saw himself in a few pinches
and he really was very humble with us
yeah honest to god i mean
my
like people are like what did you really
like about the longest yeah our mornings
our mornings people that had to be a fun
set i'd be on my trailer and he had the
last trailer
but i think he liked the cold air like i
like and i would go outside and i'd see
him and we'd meet like in the middle
and we just talked about yesterday's
scene and
you were funny yeah you were funny too
that's [__] crazy whatever and that
was it yeah there was no i didn't ask
him for a picture like i have nothing
with him yeah i think uh
goldberg took a picture of us and he
signed it for us and he gave me a copy
of his one-man show okay which i got in
the safe yeah sammy
you gotta watch this one-man show from
vegas oh i bet it's amazing and this is
taped like by a friend of his like when
he gave it to me he's like never give
this to nobody yeah this is for you
because we were talking about one-man
shows yeah and he's talking about some
wild [__] up there and he's killing
talk about watching things with your
kids my 17 year old that's his favorite
movie the longest yard by far his
favorite movie and the original no no no
no no it's yours really and then i sit
down with him after he watch i go i go i
want to show you the original couldn't
get through ten minutes of it you know
it was i don't know if it was the pacing
of it or whatever but it just was not
it would wouldn't live up to it what do
you think that is i mean what
i don't know it kills me it kills me
sometimes when i show somebody something
and i know that
like lee's a little younger
and they may not be enjoying it it's not
that pace i could see like the old
westerns are not even the old clint
eastwoods
no exactly no you sit down and you're
like all right i like it for nostalgia
and everything else but it doesn't have
the pace these shows have today
things fly today do you think your son
would have liked it more had he not seen
the problem
because i think once it gets in your
brain and you've identified it and and
because he liked it so much you know it
was just like why is this why is this
trying to be what i just watched you
know that's in his mind that's what he's
thinking i watched the original in the
movie theater yeah
and that last 30 minutes the whole
theater was on their feet oh yeah i
watched that at the same theater where i
watched
rocky where i watched tommy where i
watched uh
the exorcist where i saw anthony dragon
that was my old union city cinema
48th street 300 seats yeah for the
longest yard you left there people were
sweating from fantastic unbelievable i
think i broke his [__] nose yeah just
yeah yeah yeah crazy yeah i remember
rocky i was probably five years old when
i went to see rocky
my father took me and because my father
was real into boxing and we'd listen to
boxing on the radio or wherever we could
always see it and watch it but uh
went to uh went to see rocky and i just
walked out of there five years old it
blew my mind blew my mind i mean it just
i you know i felt like if five years old
i thought i could conquer the world you
know
it was it was amazing it's amazing i
used to love going like my mother took
me to herald and maud you ever see that
movie yes that's right i was probably
seven years old going to see harold and
maud is like all demented and weird and
strange and but i thank god she took me
to that stuff man you know that was that
was a
that was that was a good movie that was
a good movie
i went to see i think the weirdest movie
my godfather used to take me to the
movies every other saturday and we'd go
right to 42nd street
and we'd walk on the decent movie side
he wouldn't take me to the
the far that was all triple x yeah we
stayed on this side the family side got
and we would i would just pick the
weirdest things
and i still remember going to see the
first movie ever that [__] destroyed
me when i came from cuba was her majesty
secret service
it's the first james bond i don't know
that one nobody knows that one yeah they
hid that one that's got kojak in it
diana rigg
and george lazenby played james bond all
right it was all to do with skiing and
all that [__] but i went to see the
stone killer like those are the movies i
would like you go pick a movie like i
went to see one kid movie with him yeah
the love bug yeah and once he told me
that that wasn't the case i could pick
whatever i wanted to i think i went to
see the world's strongest man with jan
michael vincent okay yeah yeah disney
yeah to see that with him
but then something happened he was like
pick a movie went to see stone killer
i would go see all those crazy [__]
movies yeah once you know that stuff's
out there oh death wish yeah i was at
charles brown the first
bronson was velocity papers let's get
the [__] that's the one i went to see
and i went home and asked about the
mafia what's the [__] to mafia and they
wouldn't tell me
[__] yeah it's fun like my you know i
again like with my kids i see them watch
like the first time they get to watch
like an adult you know show or something
you know they've been watching like just
kid shows kid shows and then like
it's funny because i think one of the
first ones my son watched was breaking
bad i was like you got to check this out
check this out you know because he
watched what he watched under the dome
he watched that and uh it was a network
show but he was just like man all this
stuff crazy stuff's happening bye-bye
like buddy you have no idea i said watch
breaking bad and he just comes out of
the room like oh my god this is are you
kidding me this is crazy you know and
then just starts watching all it's fun
to watch them uh
discover that stuff what movies have you
tried to show them that they've said
that what the [__]
we gotta go
i'm trying to we gotta go
don't show this to us ever again i'm
trying to yeah but well you mentioned
like uh uh
i took my kid i took my 10 year old to
smoking the bandit they were playing it
on the big screen so i took him to see
that he's very polite i'm not so sure he
loved it but he he said he liked it but
then i've tried to show him like uh
clint eastwood any which way but loose
any which way you can you know those
movies they can't make it they can't
they can't do it even like cannonball
run like all those movies i love good as
canon love it
love it
is that the one when they
don't they get pulled over by cops and
um
sammy davis jr and dean martin come on
they start dancing is that the one yeah
i mean it's insane it's just nuts
is captain chaos yeah yeah yeah that's
the one
that's the one and you could tell they
were just having a blast a blast yeah i
mean when they started to let uh hal
needham the the stunt the stunt
coordinator he started directing those
movies you know and they were just going
nuts they were just having a blast they
had the money burt reynolds was was was
the name that was getting everything
made and they were just all buddies and
they were going out and having fun and
you can tell when dean martin
and sammy davis jr come out of that car
dressed as priest
aren't they something [__] crazy yeah
it is [__] crazy you could tell
unless you're a [__] that they are
[__] happening yeah
absolutely they were happening they
would like laugh like ah we're getting
20 000
can you believe this we're dressed up
like priests and we've been here since
eight in the morning drinking
and now they wanna they would pull up in
a limo we're [__] that that's you
could tell how much fun they were having
absolutely right yeah there was another
one they made like that not cannon ball
run what was the other spoof like that
they made something about harry an asian
one
i don't know
i know jackie chan was in uh cannonball
run run they had a couple of them one of
them they had an elephant in the back of
a
ambulance the whole time dom deluise was
taking care of it or something
it was just you look back it was crazy
but you but they were having a blast you
know for those movies
to do that type of stuff the studio
can't be around
now like they had to shoot those like
listen we're going to shoot this movie
in chicago well we'll send somebody out
there on the third week to see how
you're doing because with the studio
around they can't have that type of fun
no once the head sees those two hammers
we cannot put them on the tape yes we
got this you got to get out especially
now it's just special one take one take
one take we're going to get the light
here
that's the secret you got to get it
that's what i did with with earl and
raising hope i went as far out you know
i went to you know you go to van nuys
you get out there between two trailer
parks there's no secured parking people
are scared to come out there all of a
sudden you're all by yourself you do
whatever you want this new one i went up
to the mountains we're like three hours
up uh the five to the mountains nobody
showed up up there nobody wants to drive
up to the mountains so yeah that's the
move that's the move you get out of town
i learned that when i shot the longest
yard the six the first eight weeks in
new mexico
you should have seen it yeah they had
umbrella girls they went to albuquerque
and pulled up strippers and told me you
want a day job 200 a day three four
hours with an umbrella holding it for
the players
we came up to orange county there was no
more umbrella girls yeah there was no
more smoothies
there was no more weights on the center
the hammer went down
yeah yeah yeah yeah let me give some
shout outs
let's get this body started
jennica jones a true [__] artist this
girl does stand up she paints walls she
does murals
she's like you know her and her husband
i've met him going to san francisco a
few times and every time on her twitter
feed that's all she's got it's pretty
stuff so jennifer jennica jones i'll see
you august 12th that uh punchline emma
hagan
dead squad mufc
brian mccann
zan marino aaron giesbrite
susie cream cheese cameron sandmeyer joe
cunningham
and care94
and for all the other guys that have
been supporting us for the last uh
five years thank you very much
i said we just give him a little shout
out absolutely just to make him feel at
home and this whole [__] thing the
like before you created my name is earl
what was
what were you thinking about you won
like what did you base it on like i've
always wondered you know he's a guy that
[__] up for years now he's apologizing
for everything he did you know i had uh
i always liked shows about redemption i
believed in karma somewhat you know like
whether or not
whether or not you believe in karma like
as a magical thing or you just believe
like if you just do good stuff well you
feel good about it and good then good
things happen to you whatever but i
always kind of believed in karma i
wasn't religious brought up catholic but
that went away pretty quickly and but
but i always kind of felt like i treat
people good good [__] happens whatever
and uh i just went walking on the beach
in north carolina and i just started
trying to start think of an i'd idea now
i had a
i had an uncle who uh uh
he he would always go through uh a.a and
would always get to the to the step to
you know go make amends and everything
and that's about as far as it got and
then he start over one again
and just keep going and going and going
but so that was in my head somewhat you
know uh i had another uh some other
people in my life that were similar to
uh jamie presley you know i i used to
hang out with my buddy at a um
trailer park in virginia and uh my my
life growing up i i ran the gamut like i
had buddies that that were living over
in country literally named country club
hills and then i had buddies in the
trailer park and i was kind of in the
middle and i'd go back back and forth
and everybody would hang out together
but when i was at the trailer park
i liked it you know i just i just liked
the characters i liked walking around
there in the middle of the day i was
fascinated by the fact i'm like why
isn't anybody working how come everybody
in this place has a bigger tv than my
house my house doesn't have wheels on it
what's going on over here then you open
up a door and there's just a whole room
full of weed growing and it was just it
was just i loved it i loved the
characters of it you know and so i think
the combination of all those things when
i was walking on that beach i just
started thinking about this guy and that
he'd you know maybe he did these bad
things and how's he going to make up for
it and he's going to have this epiphany
and what have you and i kept going over
my brother-in-law and he was just
drinking beers on the beach all day and
i'd run over i go what about this you
know and i'd tell it to him and he'd get
he'd laugh and then i got it i'm gonna
go and go walk some more and i'd come
back and he drunk her and i tell him
some more and he's laughing and by the
end of the day
i kind of had the idea you know i'm like
alright well let me sit down and write
this and see uh
see if it works and i always knew that
like a show about redemption people love
redemption you know and they should you
know people anybody trying to turn their
life around you root for them no matter
where they were no matter what they did
for the most part unless they did
something really heinous to you
you know you root for them you want to
see that and uh so that made that made
it easy i think to like this guy
and uh and you could have the fun of
seeing him do a bunch of bad [__] but it
was always in the past so when you're
watching them do bad stuff you know well
this dude is trying to turn over a new
leaf so now you can laugh at it you know
as opposed to you're just watching them
in present day doing this stuff oh
should i be laughing at this do i feel
guilty about it what have you
um
so that's you know that's that's how
pretty much i came up with it the world
the [__] characters bro
yeah that's the fun part world of
characters
and like my dilemma then when i write is
i got too many of these [__]
like i had your dilemma when i came from
cuba my dad died my mom had money we had
the bookmaking operation
and then she had the bar restaurant
so everybody thought she was a
restauranteer yeah but really the bulk
was numbers cuban numbers three numbers
that was her money all right
so i lived on 205 west 88th street with
nice white people
we do santeria [__] we had to sneak the
chickens out the back door i'll never
forget sneaking the goat up to the
elevator one time and the goat didn't
want to get on the elevator he had the
brakes on and my mom's pulled him by the
horns and i'm like four going oh my god
then i went to the dentist one time and
the dentist lied to me in the building
there was a dentist upstairs yeah with
the thing and everything my mom brought
me upstairs went downstairs he [__]
uh
he kept telling me that wasn't blood
i'm not stupid i could taste blood yeah
so on the way out i stole the ivory
elephant my mom made me bring it up and
[__] this this building was crazy so was
it an office or an apartment this is
just with a chair still there 205 west
88 still there okay people will send me
pictures once i say that's when i came
from cuba we lived in jersey for maybe
six months and then once my dad died my
mom didn't like jersey she went right
back to new york city where she belonged
so this was a very on the corner it was
owned
by
the kid some [__] ugly kid that was
on dark shadows his parents hold the
camera stop in the corner all right and
he will hang out in there which my head
would blow up yeah because he's your
jenny piccolo yeah
what the hell what's going on he owned
the camera store in the [__] corner
the girl i grew up with the chinese girl
that we'd hold hands in kindergarten her
father was the chief dude for schultz in
those days okay so every time charlie
brown came out with the new movies her
and i were at the [__] movie theater
on the east side like doctors
but my godmother my santeria godmother
was on 148th street in broadway
and that was the neighborhood yeah
they did another slope the first day i
went to they showed me a dead body the
kids were like you want to see a body
like you know and what
what do you mean like six puerto ricans
and three irish kids and we went down
there and had a piece of two by four and
you could there was flies everywhere and
you could smell the thing 20 feet away
you think they gave you know how now you
see tv shows and people like take a body
to have mass these kids had no mess yeah
they were as tough as death now were you
scared or were you instantly interested
i was
instantly interested yeah because i knew
that the other side of my mom's bar i
had saw these characters at my mom's bar
so wait a second
you guys know where there's a body yeah
it's on the west side highway
yeah you know the csi didn't work that
quick those days i don't know what the
[__] happened and then we went one day
and it wasn't there no more yeah you
know i didn't hear about it the news or
nothing yeah it was just the body that
somebody dumped on the highway and it
had flies on and they put it to like a a
four by eight on it but
after you go to some kid's house yeah
and they show you
so i want to go to my godmother's house
as much as i can dead body is trialed by
fire that's big like like i dipped my
toe in it and and i was i was nervous
but it was there was no dead body i
remember the first time i went down to
this kid's house and he said he's gonna
have a sleepover and you know i'm
thinking ah sleepover okay you know
we're in like fifth grade or something
like that sixth grade i'm like oh okay
maybe we'll watch some movies mom will
pop some popcorn and whatever and my mom
drops me off and there's like eight kids
in there and it's like
mayhem already i'm like wonder where's
this guy's parents you know and then his
mom comes down she's drinking a beer
smoking a joint she says i'm going out i
got a date i see all tomorrow she's gone
and i'm like what the hell is going on
then all the playboys get out
everybody's looking to play boys
starting to drink
and it got to be about 11 30 at night
and everybody was getting up and i said
where is everybody going he said we're
going to go to the lawn mower shop we're
going to hop over the fence we're going
to steal some engines and tomorrow we're
going to make go-karts with that thing
i said i'm going to go to the bathroom i
call my mother i said you got to come
pick me up
this is crazy over here
and
she came and got me i left i i could i
couldn't handle that one so dead body i
would have [__] myself i've never felt
more connected to any guest than you
right now
because because joey tells all these
stories as a kid like that like that
sounds like joey's childhood and then
he's just like what no one else like he
looks at me like i'm crazy i know he
told the dead body i said am i really
going to tell a story about pussing out
over some lawnmower engines i would have
pushed out i wouldn't
oh my god
drinking a beer in fifth grade are you
serious
like i like them i had like i drank soda
that's all like i can't even imagine a
beer in fifth grade so
oh
i didn't drink in the fifth grade i
wouldn't even consider drinking the
fifth grade i [__] hated all that
[__] yeah in the fifth grade in the
fifth grade i was still into giggling
and you know my problem was
in the in i think it was in the seventh
grade i went to a family party
and i had uh i had a beer or two and it
just was all you needed you know i was
what 60 pounds or something oh my god
and uh and then we went to a football
game and i was i was drunk and this girl
i had a crush on she said you're cute
when you're drunk well that was the end
of that i mean [__]
i'm like well
i need more of this apparently you know
yeah but uh
but yeah seventh grade that's early
i think that's [__] early yeah a bit
early i think i smoked pot in the
seventh grade
i think i smoked pot but none of my
friends moms
got high like that that i never saw that
i'd never seen that that would that blew
my mind
that blew my mind it blew my like my mom
smoked but she didn't smoke out he
opened yeah she didn't smoke how people
smoke now like my friends never saw a
smoke or nothing like that my mom smoked
at the bar in the back manager's room
at night she'd smoke back there but no
not the way it is today yeah and i'd
[__] my pants every time she'd smoke
that the cops were gonna come like i was
one of those little [__] yeah the
cops are gonna come you know the cops
are gonna come
i was such a scary cat kid i remember
her
smoking cigarettes in the taxi cab
and throwing them on the floor and
stepping on them and me going oh this
cab was gonna blow up yeah like that's
when they had rubber there was no carpet
in those [__] new york cabs people
getting [__] stabbed in those things
there's not gonna be a carpet back there
she needed a car like my grandparents
that had a hole in the back seat so you
just i'd loved it you look down and see
the street they just you'd be jumping
around back there they tell you don't
put your foot in the hole
and just just street you just see street
that'd be good for us you just want a
butt's right out there
oh my god i had a friend who had a hole
too yeah and he had to put a piece of
metal on there is that rust it must be
yeah but they didn't put any metal on it
they just said don't put your foot in
the hole
we used to love taking that car now
you're always working on something right
yeah i'm trying to you know like you're
always writing like you're you're the
last of the real deal you get up every
morning and write something i try to
yeah even this show that i'm doing now
that's getting ready premiere they
haven't even ordered a second season
i've written two or three scripts
because i'm just like well maybe they
will so i'm gonna write them and then if
they don't use them i'll use those
stories for something else but uh and i
wrote this i told you i wrote this
broadway musical right that's right for
jimmy buffett yeah jimmy buffett that's
[__] crazy which is crazy mike
o'malley who was on yes dear who's a
writer he called me one day he says you
want to write a broadway musical and i
was like what are you talking about man
we don't know how to do that he goes ah
we'll figure it out he goes listen
that's all the the money's there the
producers are there uh jimmy buffett
it's his music jimmy buffett like my
name is earl so he wants you to be a
part of it and you'll write it with me
and we'll just come up with a story and
we'll write it and i was like all right
well i mean i can't say no i got a i got
a 19 year old who's a theater major who
loves you know musical theater and
everything i got to look cool to him got
to make some contacts for him you know
so uh we went ahead that was four years
ago and uh it's going to be on broadway
in february broadway broadway broadway
just finished up in la jolla
for uh like an eight week run run or
something like that in la jolla then we
go to new orleans houston and chicago in
the fall and then broadway broadway
february midfield do people like jimmy
buffett they love him still love him and
still yeah he sells out and people you
know and you're talking about like
doctor that's why it's good for broadway
because you're talking about doctors and
lawyers and they just come there from
work on a friday and they just go crazy
and sit in a parking lot and drink and
go nuts and then they go back to work
and these are people that buy broadway
tickets you know so i think it you know
it could work we'll see who knows but
but they just love him he sells out
stadiums still still selling out that's
just selling out does he tour constantly
yeah i mean i think he's slowed down a
little because he doesn't have to tour
as much now you know i mean but but so
he kind of does his own thing when he
wants to do it but i know my friend just
saw him in dc is 26 000 people sold out
in dc
and uh
26 000 people yeah
parrotheads
yeah they just they love them they
absolutely love them so i had a bar when
i moved to colorado we had a bar in
aspen called the paragon okay in 1983 84
it was like the biggest bar on that i
don't even know if it still exists
but that's the first time i discovered
those people okay yeah that he would
they would do something you know when i
went to i used to eat at a diner in
jersey where they had tequilaville that
record on the you know you ever go to
the east coast and they have those
little when you go to the diner in the
boots yeah yeah yeah sure yeah yeah yeah
absolutely absolutely and i would always
play i was taking it away again
yeah yeah yeah i like the song yeah i
know it's jimmy buffett yeah
and all of a sudden it's [__] jimmy
buffett it's everywhere like it's just
huge yeah he he uh he's a marketing
genius because he's got the hotels he's
got casinos
he just he's just starting uh retirement
homes margaritaville he took that one
song yeah margaritaville retirement
homes
why not yeah yeah and blenders and bikes
and shoes and
i mean it's a billion dollar you know
corporation he has over one song a six
minute song that he just he he told me
one time he goes i told the eagles man
he goes man i told the eagles there
should be a hotel california on every
corner they blew it
but uh they didn't want to do it but he
just he's he's a businessman he knows
what he's doing
a hotel california he's cornered yeah
yeah going in a little memorabilia like
yeah yeah
but back to i wanted just to
yeah characters of the whole thing
that's your that's your world
you that's what makes your
shows uniquely different
one thing i noticed about you that you
always say is i mean you create the
shows and you write these scripts
where's the rest of your writing guys
for season two
oh for for this show i wrote all these
ten myself i didn't have a writing staff
for this one because with this one it
was an odd odd journey for this one
because
i wrote these stories before it was even
a tv show i'd go up to the mountains and
i would uh
rent a house so i could write shows like
raisin hope and come up with scripts
where it was quiet up there i knew you
know writing's hard we all know
writing's hard so like you procrastinate
everything i figure if i drive up to the
mountains and pay for a rental house i
got to get something done you know i
can't come back empty-handed but
sometimes i would you know be stuck up
there i don't know what to write and so
they'd have these guest books where
people would write you know we had a
good time the kids went sledding ps the
dishwasher's not working
you know boring stuff and i picked it up
one time and i thought
what could happen in this house and i
just started walking around the house
i'm like what kind of [__] up crazy
[__] could happen and i sat down and i
wrote a 35-page story about two guys
that went up there from work and they
played cards and one caught the other
one cheating and the other guy stuck a
stuck a fork in the guy's eye and they
had this big fight and then they put the
fork back in the drawer and they didn't
know which one it was so now they feel
bad don't use the forks you know
whatever all this stuff and i made a
copy for myself i left it there just to
[__] with the next people that's it just
to freak with them and i read it to
everybody on set everybody was laughing
and then i went up there and did it
again and again and again and then i had
15 of these stories so i'd already kind
of written the stories and then i went
to tbs and said i want to do a show
about a cabin in the woods different
people come in every week and we're
gonna we're gonna make these stories
come to life you know so when i sat down
to write them i didn't really need a
writing staff i knew kind of what it was
gonna be so i just sat down and wrote
all 10 episodes and they were they were
fun to write they were fairly easy
so uh going forward i might just do that
again i don't know we'll see we'll see
if i can still keep coming up with the
stories but yeah that's that's why uh
that's why with this one i didn't have a
writing staff and it was only 10
episodes if you do 10 episodes that's
peaceful you know that's easy that's
like stress free you write them all then
you shoot them all you do 22 episodes on
a network show
you maybe have 10 scripts ready and then
you start shooting them and then
somewhere around thanksgiving you say oh
[__] we got to shoot nine more of these
we don't even know what the stories are
anymore and then all of a sudden it's
not about really making the stories
great it's about making them make sense
you know if a story makes sense then
it's good you know and that's why these
shorter orders i think when you see
these shows that do like 10 12 episodes
on netflix on cable they keep the
quality up a little bit more than the
network shows throughout it's just you
know it's just time you run out of time
36 episodes a lot of [__] episodes
this season
years ago oh yeah i remember even rogan
said he had to shoot like 41 fear
factors one year yeah like that was his
biggest order and fear factor was really
hot yeah that's a lot of work it's a lot
it's a lot of work
yeah every day grinding it out you know
uh
i don't know and it's stressful and
you've got a tough job but you
i mean i was only on the one set and it
was
i was thinking about this morning i hate
marijuana gear
i've never been privy to marijuana gear
yeah okay i don't not like it uh-huh
there's no reason why i should have a
shirt with a power leaf on it yeah and
then get mad at the cop yeah why put a
target on your back yeah i've always
been one of those guys so whatever
people give me anything marijuana-ish i
always throw it away or i give it to uh
whatever the the home over this place on
north hollywood yeah
some guy gave me a [__] there was a
dispensary the guy was a baker him and
his family got together and he was a
baker in beverly hills and he opened up
this little dispensary in a in a head
shop in hollywood and he went out of his
way and he made these gorgeous shirts
and it was just a shirt not even
marijuana but like that heart
with the thing going around it what's it
called the hemp no not [__] hemp the
the the [__] what they call these
people that smoke marijuana they call
them some compatriots or whatever the
[__] they are
all right what was the symbol for that
didn't really
uh you know it wasn't like a joint or
something but it really wasn't the the
symbol for marijuana but people knew it
as the medical marijuana people in the
no no no so it was a weird yellow shirt
and i liked the shirt it was [__]
comfortable you have a shirt absolutely
[__] comes absolutely and then i had
another shirt that i found like that the
same manufacturer like a [__] walmart
in houston and i bought because that's
where you shop when you're fat houston
and that's the oh yeah when you're a fat
[__] houston is the place houston's the
place because they cheat you on the
sizes
like right now what are you a medium
yeah i'm a medium in houston you're a
[__] double x okay because they make
you big so you get then go i'm losing
weight give me the cheesecake you know
what i'm saying they don't want you
[__] missing deals
so
what the [__] are we talking about here
i forgot the symbol of the shirt the
comfortable shirt the yellow shirt so i
get up one morning i got to go to my
name is earl i think i'm taking the
yellow shirt i bought at walmart yeah
but once i get in the [__] car
and i'm driving i look down and it's the
[__] symbol shirt
that's the last thing i wanted a tv
[__] set especially on nbc show
you're not that [__] stupid joey but
i was already three quarters up there
yeah i couldn't turn around i look for
like a clothing store again 2x is not
gonna fit i'm not walking on that set
looking like a two pound balloon in a
one-pound bag so that's not gonna happen
so i tried to turn the shirt around yeah
i turned the shirt around well the guy
had the symbol on the other side like
something he had you covered so as soon
as i walk into your set people like
what up man everybody was like i'm like
what oh hi and i didn't know what was
going on and then
i looked at the [__] thing and i'm
like oh
so i knew like i was telling you when
you walked in and when i went to that
audition
i hate those those producer ones those
five-man rules yeah i do well in them
i don't dislike them but when i saw the
look on your face it took that
like it made me say it was just joy man
i was happy to see you there you know
what i thought i was like i don't give a
[__] now
like it's my dog yeah give a [__] he
knows what i can do yeah absolutely
let's just go for it
yeah we'll [__] fight second opera
song he knows what time it is auditions
are rough man i i i i get stressed
during auditions you know because uh you
know it's so hard and i think the
hardest part about auditions and being
an actor is you come in and you read for
for a part
and
what you don't know sometimes is you
know we'll have i mean a pilot you'll
have you know whatever 100 people come
in there and read for it but just this
is an episode of tv maybe 10 15 people
come in and read for a part
you could have hired nine of them you
know nine of them could could have been
great they could be five but you gotta
pick somebody right some people look
like what is in your head so it's their
job to kind of lose it when they come in
other people you think oh that's that's
not what i had in my head and then it's
their job to get it and that'll happen
too
but everybody just gets a no for the
most part you know it's not like you get
a no with an explanation or this was how
it ranked you came in third you know
nobody you know and you so you just
gotta brush that off your back and keep
going but
that would that would be very tough that
would be very tough for me to be like
what you know was i close was it you
know to not get that feedback you're on
a set you're acting you get the feedback
somebody say i'll do this line this way
this way this way you know a lot of
times with the auditions it's going so
fast or it's just the casting director
reading and you're looking it on tape
you don't have the time necessary to
work with somebody and give notes and
you know you try sometimes when you can
but you don't always give people that
benefit so you come in you get one shot
and then you don't necessarily know why
you know it didn't work
my first two years
it would bother me yeah like not bother
me extremely i mean i'm not stupid i
know when it's a bad rate you know
i would try to prepare you know i went
to acting class the whole [__] thing
my whole thing was cold reading once
when i got here you're gonna understand
this i had a manager that was way better
than what i was
so he was getting me into big time rooms
and i was falling apart at the seams
but once i put comedy and the auditions
together
and i just said this is a seven minute
set what the [__] am i doing what am i
turning this into [__] chinese
arithmetic for i was going into like
stanislavski this is [__] comedy yeah
this is what i do what the [__]
that's when
it started clicking but it wasn't it
took about three or four years of
auditioning to get over those y's and
then one day i realized i got the
breakdowns
and that is the worst thing you could do
as an actor yeah you will shoot yourself
because you think you're right for 20
things
and when you don't go out for all 20 of
them yeah you're killing your agent but
there's variables involved there's
directors who have a brother-in-law
who's [__] needs a job where his
wife's going to [__] leave him you
know what i'm saying yeah they know that
they don't they're not gonna waste your
time
that was a one mistake i did that once
i've never gotten the breakdowns again
yeah like i stopped in 2005. like that
was that was a year of torture that was
he i hated everybody i'm not why am i
not going in for this
because there's [__] variables
involved yeah you don't know what the
[__] involved they already knew when
you write something do you know
90 of the time who you want mr g
sometimes i mean sometimes you write it
sometimes you write it with somebody in
mind that you know is is but it's a type
and you know that you're not going to
get that person or that person's busy or
something but a lot of times especially
now you've worked with so many people
you're like oh okay i think i can you
know i can write this and i think i can
get them for this or whatever yeah you
have an idea in your mind and that that
takes me back sometimes to the audition
process if i don't get that person and
somebody walks in and they look nothing
like the person then it's hard for me
until they start opening their mouth and
then then if they get the part then it's
like they earned that part because then
it was like because i was predisposed as
soon as they walked in to go ah it's not
that's not what's in my head and then
they change what's in your head and
that's you know that's pretty
spectacular for them to do that
you ever gonna shoot a movie a feature i
don't know you know i i've i've thought
about it before the problem the problem
is i mean i've been lucky that i'm busy
with tv you know and and uh i wrote a
movie one time uh i actually uh uh i had
this idea and i was palling around with
um john stamos and he was like let's
write this thing together i'm like all
right so we would go over to his house
and and uh he loved uh blue crabs from
the east coast so we'd order some blue
crabs and we would just sit and drink
beer and eat crabs every saturday and
then we'd write some of it and just have
fun i didn't know what was going to
happen with it and we got done with it
and we shopped it around and mtv was uh
mtv films they said well we kind of like
it at a meeting with us and they said do
these notes and then we'll think about
making it and then the next day my name
is earl got picked up and i said man i
can't i can't i'm busy and so that went
went that way and and i've always
thought about doing it it would be fun
um it's kind of the reason i started
directing my own shows because
what i was worried about is with a movie
you write a movie
you hand it in and that's it you know i
mean the director is the king on the
movies that's that's the way it works tv
the writer's king writer calls the shots
you know the director works for you you
hopefully get somebody you work well
with but if i if i see something i don't
like i can say hey man let's do it like
this or let's try it like this or let's
do it both our ways or whatever a movie
it just seems like you hand in a script
and then you go watch it at the movie
theater and see what they did with it
and that would drive me crazy because
i'm a bit of a control freak when it
comes to the stuff i write i want to see
it all the way through so i thought i'm
going to start directing some of these
episodes so if i do ever decide a movie
to do a movie maybe i'll have enough
under my belt where i can go all right
listen if you like this movie
let me direct it you know and and i
wanna and i don't wanna just say that
without like being prepared for it and
feel that i actually can do it you know
so now i feel that way so who knows i
mean depending on what's going on with
the tv and stuff that's something that's
certainly interesting to me and i'd like
to do everything in this business that i
can and there's something exciting about
just finding one story to tell and then
being done with it you know i'm so
kind of programmed to come up with an
idea that you can do a hundred of you
know and so even when i sit down to
think about a movie sometimes it's hard
for me because i'm like well that's a
good story but i don't know if it's good
enough for just one story you know i'm
kind of i think about things as
open-ended like let's set something up
and now we can do like a hundred of them
so that's i think a little bit of
training i'd have to do to my mind to
really sit down and write a movie after
doing so much tv on the earls you
directed all of them no no i directed
some of them though not all of them no
no i only directed probably about four
or five of them and then raising hope i
directed a few of them in this new show
i directed two of them i like doing it
it's fun and i like learning new stuff
every time but also because it's tv
and
you are you do get your say
when i can i like to bring in a director
that i work with that i like because now
there's two of us doing it you know why
should i just be there and just think oh
my way is right before i've even
exactly right and and so when you find
the right people sometimes you work with
somebody and it's like they they want to
especially if they've done movies and
stuff they come in it's going to be my
way and then you figure out okay well
we're not going to work well together
this isn't going to happen again but for
the most part you get people that
realize it's not about ego it's not
about you know i get my way or whatever
it's just about we're just here to make
the best show we possibly can and once
they realize that
then it's like it's just easy you know
everybody's just having a good time and
you throw out your ideas i throw out my
ideas we take the best ones if we
disagree we shoot it both ways you know
what have you
for at least from a writer's point of
view
even though everyone loves movies is it
more fulfilling to do a tv show
because you only have at most
two hours to 2 30 if you're really
pushing it whether it was a tv show you
could do
even one season of
20 episodes is is is longer than that so
like
even though it would be great to do a
movie do you feel like that do you like
it more because you're writing more
you know i wouldn't i couldn't answer
honestly until i maybe got the chance to
do the movie and i'm sure it would
depend on the movie but i do like that i
like working with a group right even
though in this last show i didn't have a
writing staff i like working with a
group i like i like doing that and
having the fun and the camaraderie and
everybody's busting balls all day long
and you you're there two in the morning
and you're banging your head against the
wall trying to figure out a story you
know whatever that's all you know it's
it's hard sometimes but it's also fun so
i like that and i like kind of having a
steady gig too you know like having all
right i know i got to do this i got to
go do that there's a structure to it
that i like
whereas you know with with movies i can
see how those guys don't get stuff done
for a long time when it's just you
sitting in a room and you gotta
self-motivate to write this script that
you have no idea if somebody's gonna
shoot and tv
you know they're gonna shoot something
you you're whatever you what at the end
of the day they got to shoot something a
movie you could be writing forever which
i think happens most of the time and it
just gets puts on a shelf and then and
then like what did i you know what did i
do so i like the certainty of tv too
you know what's crazy that
what the [__] was i just thinking about
that i was gonna ask you you guys got me
out of the difference
it's his fault that's his fault i
apologize no no it was interesting what
you had asked him
what the [__] was i gonna ask you
jesus christ i gotta take my bills
i don't even take pills i'm just lying
you'll remember tonight on the i at the
ice house yeah right in the middle of
the yeah right right in the middle of
this that's the worst when you have
something and you get so involved in
somebody's conversation
and so like i'm
i'm blown away that you're here i like
this kind of talk like this talk uh
you know we never really have this type
of talk with the guy in your league so
it's a beautiful i'm i'm pleased to be
here i'm happy you made it i hope people
find it interesting i'm glad we got to
at least talk about the dead body and
stuff because when i listen to the show
i'm like i want more crazy [__]
stories nonstop so crazy yeah but no i'm
happy that we're both charactery guys i
like i sit there at night and giggle
about the people that i've met in my
life yeah
i like sometimes i go jesus christ like
whatever happened to him
like within prison even
there was a black dude i met in prison
that would call his house collect every
night his wife
and at the end of the conversation he'd
go don't call back in all morning slam
the phone and walk to his cell
like you don't know how many nights i've
stayed up thinking about what is that
guy doing with his life today you know
what i'm saying he's probably not on
facebook
he probably can't can't check in on him
i mean i think that's that's part of the
fun of writing right i mean it's like
just taking all the stuff that you've
seen and mixing two characters into one
and stealing a little something from
here and there and you know even with
this this new show people were like well
where'd you come up with these like
towns people that live in this mountain
town like what tv show and movie did you
like can i go tv show a movie no i i'd
go up to the little town and i'd go to
the bar and i'd talk to people and you
know get to know people and and and you
know from real life you know um i think
for me that's that's the most fun about
it is actually going and
living things and then trying to figure
out a way to put those into
scripts you know actually leaving your
house and doing stuff
i i did this one pilot you might like
this story i did this one pilot called
super clyde
and it was about this guy that inherited
some money and he worked at a fast food
place he inherited money and then he
decided that he was going to give the
money away that was going to be his
purpose in life now we ended up shooting
it twice for cbs but it never got on but
it was all inspired by during the
writers strike during my name is earl
right about the time that you were on
because the writer's strike was kind of
right that was right in the middle of
that stuff
so the writer strike hit and i didn't
have anything to do i didn't have a job
i knew it was going to last i was going
to ask you about this yeah that's right
so so i uh i'd always wanted to write a
book about me doing a bunch of minimum
wage jobs because growing up i worked at
my uncle's lawn business landscaping i
worked at the the gas station pumping
gas
uh i had real jobs hard jobs but one
time i was sitting at the roy rogers in
in maryland eating a burger over like
christmas break or something that i was
doing yesterday at the time and i was
just eating the burger watching
everybody and i thought
can i still do a hard job you know am i
too spoiled at this point you know
people bring you your lunch you know
whatever can i still do an eight-hour
shift and i thought it'd be fun to just
do a bunch of jokes like 30 days at a
time do the job
write about it talk about my adventures
meet the people and then for a little
game show element to the book i thought
i'll pick one person
in the restaurant that works there and
at the end of the month i'll give them
ten thousand dollars and then i'll just
disappear then i'll go to the next job
so this was an idea i had but then i
never had time to do it it was always
working
and so then the writer strike came and i
thought all right i'm gonna do this i'm
gonna just see what it's like see if it
works i got my car and i started driving
up to 101 i pulled off i went past two
exit because i didn't want anybody from
my neighborhood who was gonna go get
fast food to see me i went two exits
pulled over went into a mcdonald's
filled out application went into a taco
bell wrote my name on a napkin then i
went into burger king lady sat me down
she goes let's have an interview right
now so we had an interview what did you
put down as your background yeah so i
got it i'm talking to her right and i'm
telling her that um cause i gotta
explain my driver's license i gotta
explain my neighborhood and uh not a lot
of people in my neighborhood are going
and filling out applications at burger
king right so i go well i live with this
family and i take care of their kids
during the day so i can really work from
like once they go to school from like 9
30 to like three when they finish school
because i also didn't want to like i
worked a lot of hours on my name as well
and i didn't want to also look at my
kids and go oh yeah now i don't have to
work but i'm still not going to be with
you because i'm working burger king so i
wanted to work while they were in school
so that's what i came up with my
backstory for this woman and i gave her
my friend's number and he was gonna say
that i like did some roofing with him or
something like that but she never called
and she hired me on the spot you know
so i went home and i told my wife i just
got hired at burger king she said you're
[__] insane i said no this is gonna
be good right i'm gonna get some
material from this
so i went up there i started working
they gave me a little shirt they gave me
a small it barely it barely go like it's
a belly shirt like you can see my belly
like it's so tiny and i'm uncomfortable
in the thing and i just start working on
the cashier and i'm doing the i'm
cleaning the tables and i'm a janitor
and i go home every night and i write
you know stuff about it and i'm writing
funny stuff that i think is funny about
my experience with it i'm trying to get
to know the people because i still want
to do this
game show element to it i want to like
follow it through just to see how it
works but everybody not a lot of people
spoke english they spoke burger king
english right they knew everything on
the menu and stuff they and i was
learning burger king spanish but to talk
with each other was tough i'd always
have the manager around when i try to
talk to somebody else and so she could
translate so i try to get to know people
and stuff so about two three weeks into
it
it starts to get a little boring because
i run out of stuff to write about now
i'm just working at burger king and i'm
like what am i gonna you know and i
thought i could screw around i can mess
around i can make it funny if i start
like screwing around but everybody's
working so hard they got two jobs a
manager working i don't want to be an
[__] and start messing around so i
just worked my ass off i worked i worked
hard at that place i did everything i
could to be and you know she asked me to
be in the management trainee program and
i had to say no you know this family i
work for them and she's like no listen
you know you got to take care of
yourself you can't think about this
family and
and so ultimately then the strike was
about to be over i'd done it for about a
month and i was like i got everything i
needed out of this i went in one day i
sat down she gave me i got my new shirt
got a medium she was so happy i got the
new shirt i put it on i pulled my shift
the guys were pulling me into the
drive-through it was like it was crazy i
was like it was like the first day where
i was like really part of the team you
know and uh and i sat down with her
afterwards i said listen i gotta i gotta
i gotta leave today this is my last day
and she she's what are you talking about
and i said listen i gotta be honest with
you you know i'm actually a writer i
write sitcoms and this is a book i've
been working on and i i
lied to her i told her there was already
a publisher and stuff because i didn't
want the money stuff to get weird but i
said listen and she goes well now i got
to train somebody else and i said i know
i'm really sorry i didn't really even
think about that i'm sorry but here's
the thing you know part of this book is
is i'm gonna pick one person i'm gonna
give him ten thousand dollars and so i
picked you and i gave her cashier check
for ten thousand dollars and then she
said oh my god well my god you can keep
the shirt and whatever you know
and and and i said all right well well
you know i'll take it easy and so i left
and i got in the car and i remember i
called my buddy uh the late alan
kirshenbaum and i called him up and i
said alan i just gave this woman the
check and she she just looked at me like
i was like i was crazy you know she just
she didn't know what to say and he goes
really maybe because it's the craziest
[__] thing that ever happened to her
huh and so the next day she calls me up
she says oh my god i i googled you i
watched my name as earl i love my name
as earl and she goes i told my bosses
about this you know and they're going to
be calling you they're a little nervous
that you're writing a book so now i got
the burger king guys calling me and uh
they say what's going on what are you
doing you're writing a book at our store
and i go no don't worry about it i don't
even know if i'm going to write the book
and i got to tell you i won't even say
burger king but i got to tell you a
place as clean as can be my wife said
it's going to turn me off of uh fast
food just the opposite it's clean he
goes you mentioned burger king as much
as you want man
as long as you keep saying that and they
gave me a little card that i can eat
burger king for the rest of my life
and i still keep in touch with the woman
we keep in touch she's we text on
holidays her family's come over i've
gone over to her place she had some dust
up with her husband i ended up on the
phone with him for two and a half hours
trying to talk him down
uh and they stayed together i mean it
turned into an adventure but like just
doing something like that and then
sitting back and going all right now how
can i make a tv show about this you know
how can i how can i take that experience
because i'll probably never write the
book and do it again how can i take that
experience that'll feel authentic
because i've actually done it you know i
think minimum wage jobs are a perfect
place i haven't seen it any yet but
super uh superstore i think yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah on nbc oh it's on
nbc i'm sure it's great like just the
premise of it makes me want to watch it
because some of my best friends in life
are from
the movie theater or the uh
i worked at cvs too so it's like those
two jobs
and and they all have amazing characters
and it would be perfect for television
like all those minimum wage jobs
that that you think you would hate like
you hate during a kind of you hate the
job but the atmosphere and the around
the right people and everything that's
you know that's that's those are the
stories people are going to relate to
those are the characters people relate
to and those are the good times you know
i tell people you know i tell people
that come out here and they're starting
to make it and they're like such a hurry
to get things going i'm like i've had
just i had just as much fun as a pa
[__] around with the other pas and
getting in a car and going to laughlin
nevada for the weekend and 18 of us
staying in one room that's 16 a night
and i had as much fun doing that as i
did once i got shows on and things were
working you know you just enjoy the
journey along the way it's been a great
journey man bro
this is the most interesting afternoon
i've had in a long time man
i'm happy that this uh show's working
out for you it's a great show by the way
yeah you checked i couldn't get another
link today
i totally legos uh because i called lego
league keep saying please try again yeah
it's it's he goes keep hitting it
against me tell me what to do okay all
right check it out check it i know i
know lee watched some of
she's pregnant with twins i saw her
yesterday
pregnant with twins well how many how
many kids this going to be three okay
she only has the one but now she's got
she's got two coming
two coming yeah i saw her yesterday she
was a hoot i don't know if we can play
it because it's probably owned by nbc or
one of the networks but your emmy speech
oh yeah one of my favorite can you just
did he get any trouble i mean maybe
we'll just play the audio on youtube you
can play it i play the audio because but
that was a blast because you know i
wanted to be prepared i wanted to be
prepared like you know i didn't want to
get up there and stumble and whatever
and i i have the most respect for comics
out of anybody in the industry for me
they're the top comics are the top you
got to write your own stuff and then you
got to go out there and do it the top
and so the idea that i was going to be
in front of this audience of my peers
and had a chance to make them laugh i
was like and i didn't even know cloris
leitman yet she was presenting it and i
was nervous but i i had my little card
and i and i had this speech and i and i
thought all right well let's try it
let's see what
the emmy happens to greg garcia my name
is earl pilot
[Applause]
yeah i'm nervous as hell right there i
got a xanax in my pocket i'm getting
ready to take it
look at all those people i'm terrified i
just found this last night
i got a kiss from cloris leachman
um
i don't have time to thank everybody
that i should so i thought it'd be
easier if i mention a few people i do
not want to thank
my eighth grade social studies teacher
told me to sit down and shut up because
i wasn't funny no thank you mr mcadoo
my boss when i was a pa on the show step
by step who made me clean gum off the
executive producer's shoe no thank you
ma'am tonight i do not share this with
you
and finally god i'm sure you're
responsible in some way but you took my
hair and that's not cool man
not cool
uh then it gets boring and since the
music isn't the best yeah that was fun
and i got a little taste of what it's
like to be you guys up on that stage
getting laughs and uh that's that's a
good time man that is a thrill that is
an absolute thrill
it's energy meeting energy and it's uh
it's so [__] weird talking about
characters my brother came we grew up
together in jersey he came to the show
thursday night
and he's a manager at a car dealership
and that's a show that's always how to
be explored with the right characters
absolutely but i'll never forget i
worked i was going to see you part-time
and i would sell subaru's part-time it
was a good-looking dude who worked there
and he sold cars and he had kids
and he had a wife and
from time to time he'd smoke a joint and
i knew they used to in the wintertime
they would drink blackberry brandy when
they were shoveling snow and [__]
and one day he would leave for lunch
no big deal everybody left for lunch so
people ate that lunch at that desk
one day we get surrounded by swat
[__] swat bowled the police
and also know they call us over the exit
the building
and i'm like call those in here they
came down made us all go down they shot
a a little thing into the service
department it was kind of [__] scary
yeah
and we found that that guy was a bank
robber
and he'd go at lunch and rob the
rob banks
there's a movie right there no you never
i think they even did one yeah the
little league guy that was robin banks
wasn't josh wolfe had something a little
league dude who was a coach okay but at
the same time he was robbing banks
everybody [__] robbed banks
greg garcia i want to thank you for
thank you man this was a blast again
august 3rd august 30th cbs 10 o'clock
the guest book the guest book guys and
this is the mind
of greg garcia which is just a [__]
never-ending
voice like the [__] shining
that's what's in your head at night the
[__] shining and stuff
let me just read this off we'll get you
out of here and everything will be
beautiful listen let me ask you
something we all want to eat better but
when it comes to snacks sometimes it
feels like the whole world is delicious
and a billion calories versus boring and
tasteless it doesn't have to be that way
up your snack game with nature box
nature box has over 100 snacks that
taste good and are actually better for
you all snacks are made from high
quality simple ingredients which means
no artificial colors flavors or
sweetness so you can feel good about
what the hell you're eating my favorites
are the cocoa
the number
the lentils i like the salt and vinegar
veggie chips i like the apple and
cinnamon oatmeal bars and that's just to
name a few so you're gonna find your new
snack obsession at naturebox they add
new snacks every month inspired by real
customer feedback the latest food trends
and professional chefs how you like me
now it's so simple just go to
naturebox.com
choose the snacks you want and nature
box will deliver them right to your door
and there's no risk if you ever try a
snack and you don't like it don't eat it
nature box replace it for free gratis
and right now i'll tell you what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna save you even more
nature box is offering you
the family the church of what's
happening now you savages three free
snacks with your first order when you go
to naturebox.com
joey again that's naturebox.com
joey for three free snacks with your
first order
naturebox.com
joey
i also want to talk to you about some of
the personal hygiene note like i told
you in the beginning of the show
you know it's summertime it's muggy if
you live in philadelphia by the way i'll
be in philadelphia next week and i'm
bringing a [__] portable bidet
because i know humidity kills your
[__] in the summer so i'm not going
to fall for that [__] stink trap
that's why you got hellotushy.com you're
sitting there going joey what's hello
tushie it's a portable bidet that you
install right in your bathroom within
five minutes now what happens every time
you take a little poop to poop or every
time you go for a little jog or maybe
you go to yoga you don't want to develop
no no cheese down there you sit on the
thing you put the water on it sprinkles
your little muffler you jiggle it around
it sprinkles your nut sack maybe your
helmet and there you go you got no germs
growing no no hemorrhoids you got no
swamp ass everything is tip top magoo
the way you want it to be in case you
bump into a victim you never know when
you're going to bump into a victim and
number one you always want to be
prepared that's why hellotushy.com
is the portable bidet for you not only
that we give you a 90-day money-back
guarantee this thing is sensational
elite tell them about the hello does she
it changed my life start every day with
hello toshiba that's what i'm saying
there's a buddhist religion somewhere in
this [__] mess here of people that
just pray sitting on a [__] bidet all
day with hot water cleaning your little
[__] you know what that feels like
don't discount the cold water the cold
water's even better you know why it
opens up the follicles and lets all the
junk out of that little [__] head
patch that you call an [__] anyway go
go to hellotushy.com
right now and get 10 off delivered to
your house that's how we're rolling all
right i love you guys once again i want
to thank hello tushy and once again
naturebox.com for always being a great
sponsor and i want to thank
mr greg garcia mr lee syed
my little brother here and all you guys
for 500 [__] episodes
i love you [__] have a great
weekend we'll see you next week stay
black hit it lee
[Music]
you